with your basic matches the combustible
components are split between the
matchstick and the matchbox trip but
strike-anywhere matches build all that
chemistry into the tip which means you
can ignite them on just about any
surface so what's inside these mighty
matches the matchstick itself is made of
soft white Aspen a slow burning wood
that's not very flammable which helps
protect your fingertips further
fireproofing comes from a bath of mono
ammonium phosphate or map when you blow
out the match map stops it from
smouldering the head of the match stick
is the fire starting part that white dab
on the tip powdered glass tiny shards
create friction
any way you strike it that friction
ignites potassium chlorate which
releases oxygen as it burns the same
chemical reaction that supplies
emergency air on submarines and
aeroplanes friction also ignites
phosphorus sesqui sulphide it generates
enough heat to ignite the Aspen shank
and then burns itself out and now the
secret sauce potassium dichromate a
potent highly combustible oxidizer
brands won't tell us exactly what it
does but we bet it's there to accelerate
the burn rate pretty hot right have a
burning question about what's inside
your stuff leave a question in the
comments below and subscribe to the
wired Channel